wisconsin attorney general josh call is
involved in the investigation into the
police shooting of jacob lake in kenosha
he joins us now from madison wisconsin
good to see you attorney general cole
what can you tell us about the
investigation
well thanks for having me on gail this
is an ongoing investigation
uh in wisconsin we have an independent
agency conducting this investigation so
that the
agency from that the officer works for
is not involved in the investigation
we're that independent agency in this
case and the investigation is moving
forward
swiftly but consistently with protecting
the integrity of the investigations
over 80 witnesses have been interviewed
over 100 pieces of evidence have been
collected
and the investigation continues to move
forward i was going to ask you about
witnesses and evidence and you just
answered that does any of the evidence
show
that jacob blake was holding a knife at
the time that he was shot
we're only releasing certain information
at this point in time so we can protect
the integrity of the investigation
we've released information indicating
that a knife was recovered from the
driver's side floorboard and that mr
blake
acknowledged that he was in possession
of a knife
there were also no other weapons that
were recovered from the scene that's the
information we've released
this far okay can you tell us attorney
general call why the police were
called to the scene to begin with i've
heard conflicting reports about that
they were called for a report that there
was a person
on the premises the boyfriend of the
caller who was not supposed to be there
and wasn't leaving and so police were
responding to that call
and was the boyfriend jacob blake
we're not commenting on that detail at
this time it's important as we proceed
with this investigation
that we not prejudge any facts so that
we collect the entirety of the evidence
in this case present it to a prosecutor
who will make an independent
prosecutorial decision and if a charge
is brought
that the jury makes the key findings of
fact in this case
you know the blake family as you've
heard is asking that he
the officer rustin chesky be arrested
and charged what do you need to see to
bring charges against the officer
the charging decision in this case will
be made by a prosecutor
our office conducts the independent
investigation but
the standard for the use of deadly or
potentially deadly force
is if the officer reasonably believed
that the person against whom force was
used
was an imminent threat to the life or
to cause serious bodily harm to another
we want to gather the evidence as
fully and fairly but also swiftly
consistent with that as possible so that
a charging decision can be made
as quickly as possible in this case you
were one of the officials that
asked president trump not to come along
with the governor and the mayor of
kenosha but a lot of people were very
glad to see the president
his critics are calling it a photo op
others say it inflamed tensions there
what do you say about the president's
visit
well the situation on the ground in
kenosha had been improving significantly
over the past several days
and having the president come brought
more attention to that situation
we also unfortunately didn't hear any
condemnation of vigilante violence and
as the clip that you played earlier
indicated
there was nothing from the president
about how we can work
together to address systemic racism yeah
you talk about vigilante
let's talk about that for a second with
kyle rittenhouse there is a tape that
has just been released by his attorney
where kyle was asked if he wanted to
thank his fans which i think is an
interesting choice considering three
people were shot and two were dead
uh and he thanked them for overwhelming
support but does he have a case for
self-defense his attorney says this is a
watershed moment
is there a case for self-defense here
yeah that's a case that's being
prosecuted by the kenosha d.a and not my
office
but what i will say is that our leaders
need
to work to heal our communities to bring
people together
to call for justice and refusing to
condemn vigilante violence whether it's
in charlottesville or in kenosha is
unacceptable from our leaders and so i'm
hoping we will finally hear
a clear condemnation of that violence
from president trump
all right attorney general cole thank
you very much for your time today